bonjour nicolas venir merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france elle rend
le disait un rang très particulière ce
matin pour les élèves mais aussi pour
vous le corps enseignant dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes ce matin avant avant
cette rentrée nous sommes tous très
inquiets
vous l'avez très bien rappelé il ya plus
de douze millions d'élèves qui vont se
brasser se croiser dans les couloirs
dans les classes des classes entières
qui ne peuvent pas être suffisamment
aéré qui ne sont nettoyés qu'une fois
par jour au maximum en pleine période
d'explosion du coup vide
c'est aberrant personne ne peut
comprendre les mesures entre guillemets
prises par le gouvernement
il n'y a aucun réel confinement pour
pour la plupart des gens c'est à dire
qu'il ya 30 millions de français qui se
croisent dans le métro dans les
transports notamment métropole qui se
retrouvent en écoles collèges et lycées
alors je sais qu'il ya eu des deux faux
débat sur la contagiosité des enfants de
primaire qui est fausse puisque des
études israëlienne espagnoles italiennes
et autres prouvent le contraire
mais pour ce qui est des enfants de
colère afin d élèves de collèges et
lycées des ados on sait qu'ils sont
aussi contagieux ou si contaminants est
tout de même en danger
donc concrètement nous on en appelle aux
parents non appel aux chefs
d'établissement moon appelle aussi aux
aux élus locaux pour faire quelque chose
puisque gouvernement et est composé d'un
capable d' irresponsable de gens qui
nous mettent en danger
donc nous on est très inquiet et puis le
climat sécuritaire est très inquiétant
aussi comment nous protéger
comment faire respecter une minute de
silence c'est pour mettant des mots dans
le carnet que des des élèves de familles
on va dire souny radicaliser ont
radicalisé vont être calme et on est
absolument pas soutenu le samu elle
pâtit n'a pas été soutenu par les
marchés
donc oui nous sommes tous très inquiets
par cette rentrée et nous sommes dans
une contestation total
nous allons dès aujourd'hui tout mettre
en oeuvre pour demain ne pas y aller dès
aujourd'hui certains collègues ont
décidé de faire valoir leur droit de
retrait ou de faire grève et nous
n'accepterons pas cette situation
vous voulez faire grève dès demain
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous nous
dites certains le sont déjà aujourd'hui
vous avez rappelé le contexte sanitaire
vous parliez aussi à l'instant du
contexte sécuritaire
ce matin c'est important aussi pour le
corps enseignant et pour les élèves de 2
justement un peu s'unir alors une d'été
des raisons pour lesquelles la pelle est
plutôt jeune et bien plus tôt en plus
tôt pour demain c'est que nous tenions
tout de même être présent pour l'hommage
des collègues ont fait le choix de ne
pas y être aujourd'hui est vraiment fort
ne peut pas le leur jeter la pierre je
vous répète rien n'est fait pour nous
protéger
la distanciation social est impossible
en classe entière avec les
établissements rempli le brassage est
obligatoire dans les écoles collèges
lycées
ce sont des clusters et en plus
effectivement des collègues vont devoir
tenir face parfois des élèves qui vont
refuser la minute de silence les
contester ça sera sûrement étouffé par
le ministère comme d'habitude ce sera
sûrement minoré par le ministère comme
d'habitude
et voilà nous nous ferons remonter
évidemment ce qui se passe ça je peux
vous le garantir
autre chose aussi il faut savoir que
vendredi dans l'après midi il ya eu un
cafouillage total de monsieur blanc car
avec abolition je n'insiste en
annulation abolition de l'hommage à
samuel pâti lundi n'avaient peur que
nous nous réunissions notamment par
rapport aux côtés de mais aussi à cause
de nos inquiétudes dont je vais parler
un rétropédalage parce que nous en avons
fait pas immédiatement aux médias ça a
circulé partout donc une demi heure
après monsieur blanc car nous écrivait
en dix ans ici l'hommage est plus ou
moins maintenue mais pas totalement
obligatoire mais en fait oui mais en
fait non les chefs étaient vent debout
ils ont dû organiser réorganiser
l'arrivée des élèves à 8 heures puis 10
heures les huit heures c'est n'importe
quoi c'est irrespectueux haut possible
nicolas glières qu'aurait fait qu'est ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire en fait pendant
sept cette rentrée est ce que vous vous
pensez qu'ils auraient tout simplement
fallu fermer les établissements
scolaires alors nous n'étions pas du
tout pour preuve à l'appui dans vos
archives notamment
ça fait quatre mois qu'on demande la
mise en place des demi groupes comme il
existait on mai et juin ce n'était
évidemment pas idéal c'était un effort
demandé aux parents de pouvoir s'en
occuper
quand il n'était pas en cours ou alors
demandé aux communes de les prendre en
charge dans des salles avec des
animateurs avec des gens des agents
concrètement qui existe c'est faisable
en plus le ministère dans son protocole
prévu en juillet avait pour la situation
qu'on vit prévu cette situation cette
possibilité il n'a rien fait n'a rien
écouté on continue inlassablement elle
demandé depuis le 1er septembre
rien n'est fait monsieur blanca est un
idéologue il manque en permanence il
passe son temps à dire que les écoles ne
sont pas contaminantes pour le prouver
qu'at-il fait il a baissé les jauges ils
abaisser les critères de sorte que les
classes ferment de moins en moins les
écolos chier mais il ya de plus en plus
de cas et chez les élèves et chez les
enseignants donc on a quelqu'un qui est
dangereux à la tête du ministère de
l'éducation
c'est pourquoi nous avons porté plainte
notamment contre lui mais aussi monsieur
verront vidal ils nous mettent en danger
le met en danger les élèves ils mettent
en danger leur famille nos familles ce
sont des gens dangereux il faut les
mettre dehors vous lisiez l'instant vous
avez porté plainte contre le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui exactement et
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
plainte
quand nous avons porté plainte
collectivement en tant que stylo rouge à
auprès de la cour de justice de la
république nous faisons des référés
auprès du conseil d'état
mais tout le monde personne qui connaît
un peu le droit à sec le conseil d'état
dépend de la justice administrative et
que celle ci donne quasiment tous raison
ou pouvoir où il est rare qu aux
personnes les plus haut placés dans la
hiérarchie
ou alors ils prennent pour prendre leur
décision ils l'ont fait par exemple pour
les personnels à risque ils sont plus de
200 milles plus de 200000 personnes qui
sont cons âge d'être réellement vraiment
en danger à cause du col vide danger
mortel
on a changé cette liste à la rentrée en
catastrophe pour quelques mois le moins
possible de professer sont donc plein de
gens en danger sont retrouvés à l'école
dans des salles à 35 et rien rien rien
n'a été fait par rapport à elle le
conseil d'état
le jeudi juste avant les vacances ah au
fait c'était pas légal on change on
remet la liste d'avant la liste qui
avait cours en mai juin voilà ce que
fait le conseil d'état ils traînent des
pieds il prend son temps pour soutenir
le pouvoir
c'est scandaleux concrètement ces
personnels la justice administrative
doit être abolie en france
l'administration doit dépendre du droit
commun c'était également complètement
scandaleux c'est anticonstitutionnel
merci beaucoup nicolas lire d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes un professeur de
français dans un collège du 20e
arrondissement de paris et membre du
collectif est les stylos rouges merci
beaucoup